alors je foutais un petit peu la merde
dans la famille tout de suite avant
d'accueillir les chroniqueurs qui m'ont
tous est un manga je le dis vous allez
voir il ya du très très bon dos
tu sais que je kiffe gims je kiffe
dazhou je kiffe les deux voilà mais je
vais te faire une petite interview
lequel des deux lequel des deux était le
plus nul à l'école guy mme guy nzouba
zhu
je crois c'est dur je pensais rester
toiles connues c'est cette étoile ah
ouais tu étais le c'est le top
l'élu l'arrêté tracé comme toi c'est
[Rires]
lequel des deux danses lemieux gims ou
dazhou et de ces mêmes c'est le même
moule
voilà c'est à peu près la même chose et
ça peut sont moyens les 200 - lequel des
deux t'offre le plus de trucs c'est une
bonne question ça tu peux dire chauffe
les comme ça
je crois que je sais pas franchement je
sais pas voilà les deux les deux ils
sont cools les deux ils se sont très
cool c'est vrai vous entendez bien et
c'est dingue vous faites tous des trucs
ensemble tous les frères cca c'est un
truc de ouf c'est bientôt des frères
incertains
ouais c'est bien sûr tous autour de la
table l'arrivée de barani